Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
Abbiamo poco tempo ed io sono... sono terrorizzato,
lì c'è un monitor che mi dice quanto tempo manca.
Sono diciotto minuti e in diciotto minuti ho da esporre
qualche cosa di un pochino complicato.
Io sono qui perché sono stato invitato.
A TED credo che l'invito dipenda proprio
dal lavoro che facevo, ho fatto il magistrato
per oltre 33 anni, dal fatto che mi sono dimesso
14 anni prima della scadenza naturale della mia professione
e dal fatto che oggi vado in giro molto a parlare
soprattutto ai ragazzi e a parlare della mia nuova visione
delle sanzioni, della pena, della prigione.
Questo TED è dedicato soprattutto all'amore,
c'è spazio anche per il perdono.
Bene, io credo che parlerò, anzi parlerò sicuramente
del perdono, non secondo quella concezione generale
che noi tutti abbiamo perché parliamo di perdono
riferendoci a delle relazioni interpersonali,
soprattutto relazioni molto intime, no?
Che hanno a che fare con il tradimento
e con la possibilità di recuperare una relazione
che si è interrotta, che è saltata.
No, io intendo parlare del perdono
in un senso più ampio, in un senso, potremmo dire, “sociale”.
Punto interrogativo è: ma il perdono – l'amore anche se volete –
ma il perdono può avere a che fare
con l'organizzazione della società?
Noi possiamo, cioè organizzare la società,
le nostre relazioni, le regole che organizzano,
che disciplinano il nostro stare insieme,
tenendo conto del perdono, avendo come punto
di riferimento il perdono, in questo senso, sociale?
Noi, sapete, possiamo vivere insieme
soltanto dandoci delle regole.
È impossibile vivere in comunità senza regole,
non perché l'ha detto qualcuno ma perché è ineluttabile.
Chissà quante regole stiamo seguendo adesso
senza nemmeno saperlo: io ho diciotto minuti,
vuol dire che la regola è quella e peraltro
che i minuti durino sessanta secondi anche quella è una regola.
Noi cambieremo la regola della misurazione del tempo
alla fine del mese, quando passeremo dall'ora solare
all'ora legale. E del resto ci capiamo soltanto
perché ci esprimiamo attraverso dei codici prestabiliti.
Parliamo adesso in italiano, prima si parlava in inglese,
mi è stato richiesto di parlare in italiano
per sottolineare il fatto che siamo qui a Milano quest'oggi,
che si chiama TED Navigli.
Abbiamo cambiato sistema di regole, siamo passati
dall'inglese all'italiano. Non ci capiremmo se parlassimo
delle lingue che non conosciamo l'uno con l'altro.
Anche quelle sono regole.
È impossibile vivere insieme senza regole,
perché abbiamo bisogno di affidamento reciproco.
Abbiamo bisogno cioè di fidarci reciprocamente
del nostro comportamento futuro, è per quello
che ci sono le regole. Fidarci che se si dice alle tre
allora ci troviamo alle tre, per dire.
Sono le regole quelle che organizzano la società
e se ci pensiamo, se guardiamo alle nostre spalle,
vediamo che la società è stata generalmente,
sempre io direi, organizzata da regole
che avevano come principio ispiratore,
come punto di partenza, la discriminazione.
Anche la discriminazione aveva a sua volta
un altro punto di partenza, era un punto di partenza
che riguardava la valutazione delle persone.
Le regole, cioè, sono sempre state destinate
a organizzare lo stare insieme partendo dall'idea
che le persone avessero un valore diverso,
i maschi più delle femmine per esempio.
Sapete che in Italia, fino al 1946, votavano soltanto i maschi,
non tutti peraltro. Ma questo era un fenomeno mondiale
fino a un mezzo secolo o poco più di mezzo secolo prima.
Per quel che mi risulti il primo paese che ha introdotto
il suffragio universale è stata la Nuova Zelanda nel 1893
e prima esisteva una forte discriminazione di genere,
che secondo me, in questo paese, ancora non è scomparsa
del tutto, nonostante che siano cambiate le regole.
Bene, in una società organizzata attraverso la discriminazione
e cioè una società piramidale, in cui chi sta in alto può
e chi sta in basso deve, ove esiste una più o meno rigorosa gerarchia,
beh forse più andiamo indietro più la troviamo rigorosa,
ma la trovavamo rigorosa anche poco prima
della metà del secolo scorso, quando il nazismo
e il fascismo tenevano molto alla distinzione,
appunto alla discriminazione.
In una società di questo tipo il perdono
ha qualche spazio nell'organizzazione?
Io direi proprio di no.
Nell'organizzazione sociale che cosa conta?
Conta moltissimo l'esclusione, la separazione,
il rimarcare le differenze e le diversità.
È una società, quella passata, che non dà possibilità,
che non dà spazio a quell'atteggiamento gratuito
per cui si accetta l'altro indipendentemente dalla possibilità
di trarne un profitto e in una società del genere
il perdono è escluso. O meglio, se esiste il perdono
è una elargizione del signore, del principe,
che conferma il suo potere nei confronti degli altri
che sono discriminati nei suoi confronti.
Succede, poco prima della metà del secolo scorso,
che a seguito dei terribili, degli incredibili eventi
che si sono verificati prima
(pensate, due guerre mondiali nel giro di poco più di vent'anni),
finisce la prima nel 1918 e inizia la seconda nel 1939;
e non solo due guerre mondiali,
perché contemporaneamente alla seconda c'è la Shoah,
sei milioni di persone programmaticamente eliminate:
ebrei, zingari, disabili, omosessuali, avversari politici,
programmaticamente eliminate. La bomba atomica.
La bomba atomica, che a noi può fare una certa impressione
(certo, a me non piace per niente) tuttavia devo dire
che per poco io sono nato
dopo che la prima bomba atomica è scoppiata.
A tutti noi o alla grandissima parte di noi la bomba atomica
non ha cambiato il futuro, mentre per coloro che vivevano allora sì,
la bomba atomica ha cambiato il futuro.
Mettiamo insieme questi eventi: le due guerre mondiali,
la bomba atomica, la Shoah.
Appena appena le persone hanno cominciato di nuovo a riflettere,
perché prima non potevano, la prima cosa che si sono chieste
è stata come facciamo ad evitare
che tutte le tragedie che abbiamo dovuto sopportare,
i drammi, l'infelicità, non si ripeta nel nostro futuro.
La scelta è stata quella di cambiare il modo di stare insieme.
Nel 1948, esattamente il 10 dicembre, è stata proclamata
la Dichiarazione Universale dei Diritti Umani.
Qualche mese prima, undici mesi e dieci giorni prima,
in Italia è entrata in vigore la Costituzione.
Entrambi questi atti – la prima è una raccomandazione,
la Dichiarazione Universale, la Costituzione è una legge –
partono da una constatazione che rovescia il modo
di stare insieme. Tutte le persone, tutti gli esseri umani
nascono liberi e pari in dignità,
dice la Dichiarazione Universale dei Diritti Umani;
tutti i cittadini hanno pari dignità sociale e sono uguali
di fronte alla legge, dice la Costituzione Italiana.
È esattamente l'opposto.
Se prima il principio era la discriminazione,
poi, dal 1948 in avanti, il principio sarebbe,
cioè è – ma poi bisogna vedere se viene attuato –
invece quello del riconoscimento di analogo valore,
analogo valore, positività, di tutti gli esseri umani.
Allora c'è da chiedersi: ma con questo nuovo
sistema organizzativo c'entra questa disponibilità all'accoglimento?
Ancora la società funziona attraverso la separazione,
l'esclusione, quindi la pena di morte, la prigione,
oppure la strada è necessariamente una strada diversa?
Io credo che sia questa seconda osservazione
quella che si trova in coerenza con il nuovo modo
di organizzare lo stare insieme.
Se la sofferenza – perché la prigione è sofferenza –
andava bene in una società discriminante, forse non va più bene
in una società dell'inclusione, in una società disponibile
e disposta a ricevere piuttosto che ad allontanare.
Questo vuol dire essere in grado non di avere
quella disponibilità personale intima, nella relazione stretta,
a recuperare una relazione interrotta; questo vuol dire
avere una disponibilità generale a fare in modo
che la società funzioni attraverso il recupero
delle persone che si sono allontanate.
È un grosso problema di educazione, perché in una società
verticale, gerarchica, discriminante, discriminatoria,
l'educazione a cosa deve, io direi, necessariamente tendere?
All'obbedienza. La società verticale, la società piramidale,
funziona soltanto se le persone sono educate ad obbedire,
perché non sopporterebbero altrimenti il discrimine.
In una società, invece, basata sul riconoscimento generale,
l'educazione che scopo, che fine può avere?
Anche qui esattamente il contrario: non più educazione
alla obbedienza, ma educazione alla capacità di essere liberi.
E se le persone nascono libere poi debbono essere capaci
di gestire questa loro libertà, altrimenti
invece che avere relazioni, rapporti, avere la possibilità
di riconoscere, ecco, la libertà altrui, si ritorna necessariamente
al vecchio sistema. È necessario che, quindi, l'educazione
debba tendere a fare in modo che le persone
siano capaci di gestire la loro libertà,
che vuol dire contemporaneamente anche responsabilità.
E questo si può fare mettendo le persone in gabbia?
Ma provate a fare un esperimento con voi stessi.
In Italia, oggi, chi sta in prigione – nella generalità,
perché poi ci sono le eccezioni, ci sono anche quelli
che si chiamano lavoranti in gergo, si chiamano lavoranti,
alcuni scopini perché sono quelli che puliscono, ci sono quelli
che portano su la spesa e così via – la generalità delle persone
che stanno in carcere – provate a fare l'esperimento
su di voi – sta chiusa in una cella che generalmente
è grande meno di 12 metri quadri e non sta chiusa da sola,
ci sono di solito almeno altre tre persone;
ci sono due letti a castello di qua, ci sono due letti a castello di là...
12 metri quadri è 3x4. Dodici metri quadri
chiusi 22 ore al giorno, avendo a disposizione non un bagno,
ma una specie di bugigattolo in cui c'è un water di qua
o una turca e un lavandino, nel quale le persone,
che stanno chiuse lì dentro, fanno anche da mangiare.
Avendo la possibilità di relazionarsi, di vedere,
di incontrare i propri cari per 6 ore al mese, soltanto 6 ore al mese
e avendo delle difficoltà enormi, tanto che si può dire
che è esclusa la possibilità di ricorrere
al proprio medico di fiducia se si sta male, al dentista
se si ha mal di denti e via dicendo.
Ecco, voi provate a valutare su voi stessi:
se foste sottoposti a un trattamento del genere
per, poniamo, ma mica tanto, facciamo sei mesi,
una volta usciti avreste una disponibilità amorevole
nei confronti del resto dell'umanità
o cerchereste piuttosto di rivalervi?
E cioè, “come sono contento di poter riallacciare rapporti
con il resto delle persone!”, oppure “ve la faccio pagare!”?
Provate a fare l'esperimento su di voi.
Non è in sintonia, non è più in sintonia,
ci vuole qualcos'altro, ci vuole qualcos'altro.
Bene, nel 1989 le Nazioni Unite hanno emesso
una raccomandazione in cui si parla di giustizia riparativa.
Due, tre anni dopo ha fatto lo stesso il Consiglio d'Europa,
una raccomandazione a proposito di giustizia riparativa.
L'Unione Europea non ha fatto una raccomandazione,
ha preso una decisione quadro e cioè ha vincolato
gli stati che partecipano all'Unione ad introdurre
nei loro ordinamenti un sistema di giustizia riparativa
a fianco a quella tradizionale.
Che cos'è la giustizia riparativa?
La giustizia riparativa, secondo le definizioni
di questi organi internazionali, consiste in un percorso,
in una procedura, in una procedura attraverso la quale
la persona che ha commesso il reato e la persona che l'ha subito,
adeguatamente preparati da un facilitatore, da un mediatore,
chiamiamolo come vogliamo, una persona esperta però,
che li accompagni su questa strada, possano arrivare
a incontrarsi, in modo che, attraverso l'incontro, da una parte
la persona che ha commesso il reato si renda conto
del male che ha fatto senza con ciò essere subissato
dai sensi di colpa, capisca che cos'è il male insomma;
e dall'altra parte la persona che il reato ha subito, che oggi
è abbandonata a se stessa in questo paese, possa ricomporsi,
possa essere recuperata, possa essere riparata e cioè
possa riacquistare quella dignità che il reato aveva frantumato.
Questo è il percorso, che è un percorso che ovviamente
tiene conto anche della pericolosità.
Certo, se una persona è pericolosa è bene che stia
da un'altra parte, che non possa sviluppare la sua pericolosità,
ma questo non vuol dire sottrarre, a questa persona,
i diritti fondamentali che sono quelli
di avere uno spazio vitale per esempio,
quello di avere una possibilità di igiene tanto quanto gli altri per esempio,
quella di poter mantenere le sue relazioni affettive
e anche le sue relazioni intime, quella di poter mantenere
la possibilità di informarsi, di acculturarsi, tutte queste cose,
di farsi curare i denti da un dentista di cui si fida.
Tutto questo accompagna la giustizia riparativa,
ma la giustizia riparativa è possibile
se non ha una base comune con questa possibilità,
con questa voglia, con questa disponibilità al perdono?
Io credo che sia impossibile
e siccome perdono e amore hanno la stessa radice,
ecco la ragione, credo, per cui mi hanno invitato a parlare oggi.
Buonasera.